[تصفيق]
للاسبوع الحادي عشر على التوالي يواصل
الامريكيون مظاهرتهم في العديد من المدن
احتجاجا على الحرب في غزه مطالبين اداره
الرئيس جو بايدن بوقف دعم اسرائيل
وتزويدها بالسلاح ووقف ما يسمونها حرب
اباده وتطهير
عرقي نريد وقف اطلاق النار وانهاء
الاحتلال الذي لم يبدا فقط قبل 80 يوما بل
قبل 7
عاما وحرص يهود امريكيون على المشاركه في
الاحتجاجات مؤكدين ان ما يجري في غزه من
جرائم حرب لا
تمثلهم معاداه الساميه تعني دوله اسرائيل
الصهيونيه التي تزرع الكراهيه وسفك الدماء
واشعال الحرب بين المسلمين
واليهود لا تقتصر الاحتجاجات هنا على
المظاهرات والمسيرات فقط فمع استمرار
الحرب وسقوط الاف الضحايا اتخذت
الاحتجاجات اشكالا كثيره واستهدفت شخصيات
ومؤسسات كثيره
ايضا اياديكم ملطخه بالدماء واحده من
لافتات كثيره رفعها محتجون امام منزل
مستشار الامن القومي جيك سوليفان وهي
واحده من عشرات الاحتجاجات طردت مسؤولين
كبارا حتى امام منازلهم كما استهدفت
مؤسسات صنع القرار مثل البيت الابيض
والكونجرس والسفاره الاسرائيليه وشركه
الاسلحه الكبرى مثل لوك هيد
مارتن قطع الطرق والجسور الرئيسيه في
بنسلفانيا وكاليفورنيا وطريق مطار نيويورك
كان ايضا من اساليب الاحتجاج رغم انها ادت
الى اعتقالات وعرضت بعض المشاركين لمخاطر
في وظائفهم
وحياتهم وهذه مشاهد تمثيليه لعمليات قتل
ودمار فعليه على ارض فلسطين في غزه
وجثامين دمى اطفال احتجاجا على قتل النساء
والاطفال وهذه المجسمات للقبور تعكس
الكلفه الباهضه للحرب في ارواح
الفلسطينيين الابرياء يقول هؤلاء انهم لن
يوقفوا احتجاجاتهم حتى تتوقف الحرب عبد
الفتاح فد الجزيره
واشنطن